the summer movie season is here and it
is kicked off with Iron Man 3 I love the
summer movie season it's like I'm home
Iron Man 3
so Iron Man 3 is the third Iron Man
movie this is the first Marvel movie
that's in a post Avengers world we'll
call it the first Marvel movie of The
Avengers phase 2 leading up to the
Avengers 2 and now we meet Tony Stark
and the dudes going through some
problems guy went up through a wormhole
save New York in the Avengers so
naturally he's he's a little messed up
it's got that post-traumatic stress [ __ ]
going on he can't sleep at night so he
just buries himself in his work and now
we got the Mandarin and Tony Stark has
to save the day again sounds simple but
it's actually a pretty complex movie the
Iron Man 3 is not directed by Jon
Favreau and you can tell this is totally
different tone to it it's a bit darker
but it does have humor also it's the
darkest of the Iron Man movies yet the
funniest of the Iron Man movies makes
sense it should because that's what it
is
there are some tonal contrast where
you're like it went from dramatic and
then a joke did it fit perfectly no but
it did work it never lost me I was never
like ah blue it was never [ __ ] when
the humor happened it usually made me
laugh sometimes in the movie I was like
oh you're overdoing the humor a little
bit did it compromise the drama maybe
but Tony Stark is a narcissist that's
how narcissists deal with dramas they
don't deal with it they deflect with
humor it was never cheesy the humor
wasn't cheesy the Iron Man 3 is the most
comic book II of the Iron Man movies
I thought Iron Man 1 was actually pretty
grounded I was like okay it's a guy and
he's captured he built an Iron Man suit
he becomes a hero and he changes his
ways how we got Iron Man 3 and more
comic book II [ __ ] is happening in this
movie not that it's a bad thing because
it recognizes that it is opposed to
Avengers world yeah
Tony Stark fought with a god with a
hammer to save New York and the world
naturally this one can be a little more
comic book II and still not cross that
line one of the things I liked about
Iron Man 3 is it takes it back to what I
loved about Iron Man 1 in Iron Man 1
Tony Stark was a genius and we got to
see that he was a genius his suit is not
his greatest weapon his brain is and I
love seeing that Iron Man 2 I felt lost
I yeah the guy came up with a new
element a little things in life but we
didn't get to see that MacGyver type
genius enemy no where's like here's a
box of scraps make an Iron Man suit in
Iron Man 3 we actually get to see that
we get to see more about how his
intellect is his greatest weapon and
when I was watching this move
I was like that might be one of the
gripes that people have with Ironman 3
because it's the same gripe that people
had with the Dark Knight Rises Dark
Knight Rises people were like there's
less Batman more Bruce Wayne Iron Man 3
I will say it feels like there is more
Tony Stark less Iron Man there is a big
part of me that does wish that Iron Man
himself was in the movie more that being
said they did what they did with Tony
Stark very well and they do make up for
it in the last act of the movie there's
there's a lot of metal when Iron Man
comes to play he comes to play and he
wrecks some [ __ ] and it is badass crazy
cinematography Iron Man's all flying
around how Iron Man should because he's
being all iron many Iron Man is a word I
made it right here but the movie does
illustrate that the core of Iron Man is
Tony Stark
it shows that Tony Stark really needs to
hold on to Iron Man because it makes it
it gives him purpose but in the end it's
all about Tony Stark there's even a
little kid in the movie and the little
kid didn't piss me off he was annoying
but he was annoying in that lovably
annoying kind of way he's supposed to be
annoying because he's supposed to
irritate Tony Stark and it works and you
see that so it's kind of funny that Tony
Stark
throws sarcasm back to this kid you're
like whoa you said that to that kid I
mean granted I've wanted to say that to
kids you actually did that was actually
not that was cool good job now there is
a direction they take in this movie at a
point about halfway through the movie I
was like oh that's interesting some
people are gonna be pissed I'm gonna
tell you what it is not gonna spoil it
for you I'm just saying some fans out
there gonna be like done and other
people will roll with the movie and that
will be the thing Iron Man 3 is a very
dividing movie people will walk out of
this movie
rolling with certain things they do in
the movie or walk out going nope nah not
me I myself was one of the people that
walked out of Iron Man 3 going alright I
can roll with that
if you're one of the fans out there
who's like nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] they
didn't need to do that I hate that they
did that I hate it I'm not gonna tell
you you need to get over it because I
understand if I was attached to this
lore I would hate it too and so much
happens in this movie that the movie
feels look at half an hour longer than
it actually is it's a very investment
mood oriented movie I can watch Iron Man
1 all the time my friends could be like
you want to watch Iron Man want to be
like yeah sure I got nothing else to do
and even if I am doing something to put
it on why not Iron Man 3 is one of those
movies where it's like I have to want to
invest my time in it is very thick with
content you need to lock in amulet okay
we're gonna lock in for 2 hours 15
minutes no casually watching Iron Man 3
in the end
as a whole I will say Iron Man 3 is
worth buying on blu-ray it was a great
sequel it's the most comic book you have
the movies but that doesn't matter
because gods and Loki and all that that
did happen right so Iron Man 3 have you
seen it what's your favorite Iron Man of
the three whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more